I'm changing my tie to an alkali metal tie.
You have an alkali metal tie? It's a new tie I just got.
This one's a Dutch one. I was given it on Saturday
So here you can see we have the alkali metals (And where are they?) Here.
And the alkali metals are very reactive.
So, we've seen that lithium doesn't react very much
but then as you go to sodium
and then to potassium
and rubidium
the violence of the reaction gets more and more and more.
In cesium it's even greater.
I don't know wether the people making this tie were so frightened that they didn't put it on.
But in each of these cases the reaction is removing one electron after another,
one electron from the outer shell of the atom,
and the bigger the atom, the easier it is to remove the electron.
And as you go down the periodic table,
the size of the atom increases so it's easier to remove the electron.
So francium would almost certainly be even bigger than cesium,
because it's a whole row lower down.
And so, that should react with water with enormous violence.
But, unfortunately, francium is very radioactive
and you can't get a nice lump of francium the sort of size that you'd like to throw in water
to make the YouTube video of the century.
Francium was named after France, was discovered by one of Madame Curie's pupils
in 1939, five years after Madame Curie herself died.
I always thought it was Madame Curie herself that discovered it
but in fact it was discovered after her death.
But its properties would probably be  similar to those of cesium
if it was not very radioactive.
But radioactivity like that makes it very difficult for chemists
to study the chemistry in enormous detail.
Chemical reactions are really quite sensitive to temperature
and radioactive materials, as they decay, give out energy
so the compounds themselves tend to heat up.
A lump of Plutonium, which is very radioactive, is really quite warm to touch.
And francium, which I think is more radioactive, is probably very warm.
So I think the melting point of francium will be lower than that of cesium
because the melting points go down the group,
and because it will be generating heat,
almost certainly francium will be liquid at room temperature.
But I've never seen it.
It might well be colored, as well, because cesium is golden colored
so I would not be surprised if francium was red.
But I have no idea. And I'm not sure if anybody knows.
. . . . . . . . . . . .
Captions by www.SubPLY.com